welcome back it's time for
great celebrity X's
[Music]
[Applause]
talk about a not so Grand Slam out of
the blue former golf great Martina
Navratilova
attacked me on Twitter yesterday she
wrote quote Greg Gutfeld is a
misogynistic and not a funny at all ass
wipe
I know misogynistic not funny ass wipe
only one of those is true
but I didn't find out until this morning
and it hurt me I thought martini and I
had ended things on Happy terms
I mean sure in the 80s we were hard to
have you got a few fights but people
change and I moved on but I don't think
she has moved on and I get it I get her
career is on its Wane and mine's
completely insane so that's that's I
know what this is about but you know
nothing happens in a vacuum unless you
go downtown and pay for it apparently
Martina was responding to a tweet with a
link covering what I said on the five
about the Democratic party no longer
representing American families and
nothing makes lesbians from the Czech
Republic matter than opinions on
American families
I remember when I was watching the
protests after 2016 when Trump won and I
saw the protest
it was a lot of single women it wasn't a
lot of men and the men there they
weren't Exquisite specimens let's be
let's face it but I saw a lot of young
angry females and the Democratic party
in a way has become the party of young
angry single women
and Martina proved me wrong the Dems
aren't just the party of young angry
women but also old angry women
from the Czech Republic
I did I'm joking I Adore You Martina I
know what this is about
my comments about women in the
Democratic party that's not it it's
about my views on tennis it's been no
secret that I was working on a highly
explosive investigative piece on the
sport and that's what set her off let's
check it out
Gutfeld investigates
tennis once the sport of Kings now
celebrated around the globe but is there
a Sinister secret behind this game's
origin could it be a pathetic imposter
of a truly greater sport an electrifying
game fun for all ages pickleball
consider pickleball has a net so does
tennis pickleball uses rackets so does
tennis pickleball uses balls so does
tennis the only difference pickleball is
fun and interesting tennis is boring and
satanic conclusion the multi-billion
dollar tennis industry was built on a
foundation of lies and stolen from the
Brilliant Minds who gave us pickleball
Pirates what do you make of this attack
on
there's only one way to settle this yeah
you and her need to play Pickleball yes
[Applause]
got failed her let's get it on book it
let's do it the US Open just finished
they got an open court over there let's
do it I it's been what 20 decades since
the last time a woman athlete beat the
hell of a smart ass little man at the
time
[Applause]
Emily uh wow huh Martina I used to watch
her when I was a kid like in the 50s
he's a strong woman who's older her or
Biden I don't know
Emily I know well I'm protective of you
I don't like that she lashed out
publicly makes me angry it makes me
angry he loves it I love it he's already
sent her a safe word
it's true I mean this is she knows this
is what gets me hot
when people I like I like abuse I like
it when people abuse she knows I like it
she clearly she clearly loves you yeah
yeah no that's true that's why she did
this besides I've defended her against
the trans Community who attacked her so
I think she has the hots for me and I
know she doesn't really go that way but
you know well we both share at the same
interest I mean it is you so yeah but I
I agree with Taurus I think that a a
pickleball uh match would settle it
um you could have like a larger racket
yeah with a longer handle yes to make up
for any are you describing a frying pan
you do that
I don't I don't like you anymore Corey
yeah she just wants to date you no
that's not what it is that's basically
all it is yeah I mean look that the
Tweet was so pathetic and uh I think I
looked it up and I saw there was only
maybe like 10 likes on it so I want to
get too worried about it yeah what does
it say about you that there was only 10
likes oh yeah it's like 400 000
followers and the Tweet has 10 likes it
wasn't really popular I don't know how
it got picked up by anybody no it when
you raise a very good point things on
social media do not exist until somebody
tells you about it and it's like don't
tell me about it except this was great
because it made a great segment but it's
why do you tell people about something
they will never see that's the problem
with social media is people don't know
how to shut it off hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else